like the minimum wage law it's so it's
so easy
like that you can be
i think you don't even need to be an
economist to understand that if you jack
the price off of something people less
people are gonna do it yeah so a lot you
know who hurts a lot from minimum wage
laws teenagers yeah because if you say
we're only hiring people like let's say
they jacked it up to 30 an hour
who are the first people that are gonna
go the least skills yeah teenagers
okay and low skilled people that are
trying to move up they can't get those
jobs yeah and like that's like to me
that's so why why when they march the
streets and they act like they're
fighting for the little guy they're
saying oh we're doing this for poor
people but that's not what happens my
parents run a business yeah if you jack
up the prices they either go to other
countries and hire people
or they just don't they figure out how
to hire less people and it's the same
people that say oh i'm doing such a good
job i'm helping out poor people but
they're not doing [ __ ]